hey Dr Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about protein and the
different types of protein I always uh
get this question what type of protein
should I consume and so let me just kind
of go through some things with you uh we
have red meat right here and this could
include uh lamb and uh beef and bison
there's some positives to this number
one um it's a complete protein and
there's very few people have allergies
against this meat the negatives are that
it's a little bit harder to digest for
some people if they get a little older
okay cuz your stomachs you have to it
takes a good digestive system to digest
uh red meats um one way that you can do
this is just to chew it longer um and
also um have a smaller piece uh instead
of a Texas style steak um
okay the drawback is that not all of
it's usable or bioavailable so we can we
digest um a good portion but not the
whole thing there's other types of
protein that are a little bit more
bioavailable but this is not a bad thing
people are freaked out about it but
really what you should be freaked out
about is the commercial factory farm
beef because there are so many
antibiotics um hormones and even the the
grains that they feed these animals are
all GMO especially like the soy and the
corn so you need if you're going to
consume red meat you're going to have to
do the grass-fed or organic or High that
has a higher omega-3 fatty acid or
pasture raised okay so that's the best
way to consume meat um but the problem
is going to a restaurant so be careful
with that because of those antibiotics
poultry uh chicken turkey uh easier to
digest less expensive than red meat um
unless it's
organic uh you're getting a large amount
of Arsenic and for
Malahide I'm sorry that's what you're
that's what's in there they use fahid
for the feed for poultry as a binder and
it's uh it's legal I don't know why
they're even using
Prozac uh for these chickens to chill
them out so they that the meat is not is
more tender because they're so stressed
out because they're Factory farmed
antihistamines vadrol caffeine this is
crazy so when you go out to dinner and
you consume chicken or you go to a fast
food place or you go to the grocery
store realize that unless you're doing
the organic you're getting all this crap
in here so organic is non- GMO feeds
free
range um you know use smaller Farms like
a small farmer like a from a a local uh
place that is around your your
neighborhood is a lot better and then
I'm going to talk about eggs down here
but I just want to mention since they're
connected um is it the chicken or the
egg well let's talk about the chicken uh
egg yolks are very very healthy for you
it's almost as if it's a um a
multivitamin mineral and eggs are
probably the most perfect food that you
can eat you can pretty much live on eggs
but a pro the problem is you want to
have them organic um if the egg yolk is
organic and and pasturage if it's really
good and it's and these chickens are
eating like lot of the grass and other
types of feed that's not all grain GMO
grain then the yolks will be very bright
orange okay so I think there's a really
good one's called the shannond DOA
Valley eggs if I'm not Mist mistaken
I'll actually put a link down here I'll
go I'll actually find that um the type
of eggs that I eat and I'll put a little
link underneath it um but anyway we have
um the egg yolks should be bright and
when you crack them they should be kind
of hard to break not so flimsy and easy
that just means there's more calcium in
the
shells um
okay egg yolks that are grass-fed uh
have a lot of vit vamin K2 that's good
for the arteries um and
then one of the best quality proteins
very nutrient dense but if it's not
organic there's a lot of antibiotics and
hormones okay um so again we want the
grass fed I like the small farms it's a
little more expensive but if you're
paying even $5 for a dozen that's not uh
expensive I mean you pretty much only
eat you know two three four eggs at a
time and you can get quite a few meals
out of that so it still comes out pretty
good it's a high quality protein I like
eggs the best out of everything okay so
now poultry uh and then we talk about
fish high quality protein no carbs great
omega-3 fatty acids okay so fish is
really good but if it's farm raised
there's higher amounts of mercury
there's um lower omega-3 fatty acids um
there's other problems that they other
things they put in the feed and dioxin
so we want to consume wild caught fish
as the ideal scene okay all right pork
highly
digestible not any worse than the red
meter poultry because of all this stuff
right here um very high in vitamin B1
but you want to avoid pork from third
world countries because they pretty much
eat garbage and waste um High antibiotic
uh injections unless it's organic so
if you consume pork that is free range
but it's very rare to find it I don't
think there's a problem with it if
that's a clean animal I do not think
there's a problem with it compared to
this I mean I don't know why people
would have chicken and not pork they
think it's a dirty animal these other
dirty animals right through here both
these unless it's pasture raised Farm
unless it's not farm factory farm okay
let's talk about Dairy um dairy uh most
milk is is uh cooked at 160° it's kind
of a dead protein and there's a lot of
problems with it um hormone wise
antibiotic wise um if you can find raw
milk from a farmer that's great but in
our state it's illegal so that's a
problem so there's a lot people a lot of
uh people are allergic to it uh to the
casine protein and also the lactose
intolerant um and also pasteurization
destroys most of the nutrition okay so
milk by itself is not good but when you
ferment the milk and you make yogurt
that's a little bit better because
you're getting the friendly bacteria so
fermentation increases the protein amino
acid content
and and the microbes that'll help your
gut so but yogurt is a little bit higher
in
carbohydrates than cheese so I would
recommend if you're trying to lose
weight do more cheese than yogurt um
okay so we want to
do whole milk yogurt don't buy the
lowfat yogurt don't buy the no fat
yogurt um it's hard to find it and I
don't know why people are taking the fat
out that's the best part for nutrition
wise um you have all these fat cyle
vitamins in there but it's not going to
put weight on you so I I I always go for
the whole milk with the cream on top if
you can find it cheese very high quality
protein uh I'm not talking about valvita
though I'm I'm talking about European
cheeses that you can get from Trader
Joe's or Whole Foods or some of the
store
that has cheese that is not with
hormones that are grass-fed cows um or
or sheep or um goat cheese on in other
places like France Switzerland Australia
they all have really good cheeses that
are grass-fed and uh so that's what I
consume higher protein very low
sugar very low allergies in a high
quality cheese by the way and there's no
hormones or antibiotics so I do consume
cheese and yes I am from Wisconsin so
that's a good source Kefir is way better
than yogurt it's a sour type of
fermented drink it's less sugar uh more
microbes make sure you get the grassfed
that's the best and you're good to go we
talked about eggs soy it's a high uh
protein uh food if it's fermented it
might be okay in small quantities if
it's organic unless you're trying to
reduce estrogen but typically most
people are highly allergic to it it's
one of the most um destroyed products
because they 90 I think over 90% of all
the soil is genetically modified so
that's a problem so you would have to
get organic and most the diet programs
use soy protein isolates which is really
bad it's in Morning Star it's in a lot
of the prepackaged foods and that
creates major problems in our digestive
system and other in our livers so I do
not recommend recommend it and um so we
want to avoid soy unless in small
quantities if you want to do it I mean I
don't know I think if you've tried
everything and you're menopausal and you
have hot flashes and nothing's working
for the hot flashes take some fermented
organic soy uh I have no problem with
that in small amounts it will help you
okay
um chlorella that's kind of like a algae
and it's a plant protein very complete
but because it's grown on lakes it can
pull some toxins from that lake so
that's one of the problems in chlorella
uh can detoxify your body so a lot of
times people when consume it too much
they can detox and get a detox reaction
uh the other problem the drawback is
it's very very
expensive um but you can have it in
small amounts okay spirulina is a good
source of protein too very avable it
doesn't have any cell wall so it goes in
like a rocket ship but it can also pull
toxins and it's like 15 to $80 a pound
with protein so it's a little more
cheaper to have some of these other
proteins up here
um and it tastes
like like grass and
seaweed okay hemp
protein okay so that's similar to our
blood protein you you do it's a good
source of protein not all it's not very
complete but it has some protein but it
does create some bloating unfortunately
so that's kind of the drawback so that's
pretty much my summary of the protein um
I pretty much consume some red meat uh
grass-fed poultry some fish I even do
occasionally pork if I find it but not
too much uh I do a lot of cheese and
eggs and I do kefir that's that's what I
do